this race for this is phase four thank
you now there's a lot other stuff we
didn't get a chance to talk about today
phase four of the MCU has officially
been revealed and fans are really
excited but with the cliffhanger that
Kevin Feige left us at the end of the
hall edge panel at San Diego comic-con
many fans are wondering what is phase
five and when is it going to happen
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
as it turns out we have a lot more
details about phase five than people
actually think including when it's going
to happen and what most of the movies
are many fans have noticed that Marvel's
phase four is actually quite shorter
than the last phase that was announced
in fact Marvel's phase four only goes
from the year 2020 to the year 2021 so
it's only about two years long however
thanks to multiple interviews with Kevin
Feige the head of Marvel Studios
directly after the reveal of phase four
we have learned that phase five is
complete so I'll break down everything
that we know about phase five in this
video and a quick reminder about my Xbox
one and ps4 giveaway at 500,000
subscribers I'll be picking one winner
and they will get to choose which one
they want and I'm also still giving away
some Marvel Legends items as well if you
would like a chance to win be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway so again thanks to multiple
interviews we already know a lot about
phase 5 in an interview with MTV
directly after the phase 4 reveal at San
Diego comic-con Kevin Feige told them
that they already have phase 5 complete
not only that but they almost announced
phase 5 at San Diego comic-con as well
in the interview Kevin Feige said we
debated what we should announce today
should we announce four and five we've
planned them out we've got five years
down the road and I was like I think 11
projects in two years is plenty
so Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios has gone on record and said that
phase 5 is in fact complete and if many
of you have probably noticed that he
actually announced most of what is
coming in phase 5 at the end of the hall
age panel at San Diego comic-con right
before he got off the stage there's a
lot other stuff we didn't get a chance
to talk about today
we even mention they were making it
Black Panther - we didn't we didn't
mention the fact that guardians galaxy 3
is coming you have time to talk about
Captain Marvel - I didn't even have time
to talk about the Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about
mutant
so as you just heard Kevin Feige has
phase 5 already planned out and he
mentioned a lot of movies that were not
in phase 4 so most of these are going to
be coming in phase 5 and as you just
heard we have a black panther 2 coming a
Captain Marvel to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 blade the Fantastic Four
and mutants now for those of you who are
wondering when Kevin Feige says mutants
he is talking about the x-men he's an
x-men or the change of all I just said I
just said mutants and for those of you
who were worried about there being no
mention of Deadpool at San Diego
comic-con have no fear Kevin Feige has
cleared the air and said that he
considers Deadpool a mutant he shared
this with Nerdist directly after Hall H
I did mention mutants on the way I put
that boy in that category and then not
to mention the New Avengers who Kevin
Feige said were coming as well in an
interview with MTV Kevin Feige was asked
if he knew what the next Avengers look
like and he said yes and it will be a
very different team than we've seen
before
so even though phase 5 is not officially
revealed yet Kevin Feige did go on
record and said that phase 5 is complete
and mapped out and so far what we can
expect for phase 5 is going to be
Captain Marvel - black panther 2
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 blade
Deadpool the Fantastic Four mutants and
a new Avengers this is an insane phase 5
lineup and could possibly be the most
exciting face of the entirety of the MCU
so let me know what you think about
phase 5 in the comments down below also
be sure to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof